writing reading typing texting written
language is just one of those things
that's always been around it's a natural
way for you to use words it's a given
but there's something you've forgotten
it's understandable after all it's been
a very long time a long time since no
one on the planet knew how to write our
story starts with a legend the tale of
Thoth and Thamus no that's not a lisp
ear hearing Thoth and Thamus Thoth and
Thamus after the Egyptian god Thoth
invents writing he runs to King thamus
to share this discovery but to his
chagrin the king isn't impressed at all
looking down his nose he starts
pontificating on the destructive power
of this newfangled technology Oh clever
Thoth this invention will produce
forgetfulness in the minds of learners
with the neglect of their memory because
their trust in writing comes from
strange external marks and not their own
internal recall the drug you've
discovered isn't a memory enhancer but a
mentioning enhancer and your offering
students pretend wisdom not truth this
sounds strange it's easy for you and
your world full of writing to dismiss
Themis but hear him out he brings you
back to the early days of writing when
it was the hot new thing and like many
other inventions not everyone was on
board ok so let's say for the sake of
argument you don't want writing what are
the alternative technologies you could
bust out your abacuses they'll help with
counting and doing complex calculations
maybe you prefer icons ritualized images
that help you relate to culturally
significant figures events and attitudes
the quipu is an amazing Incan
information storage system using cords
colors and knots
and don't overlook rote memorization a
basic option sure but it's really useful
in preliterate societies where sentences
can be memorized and recited by the
thousands your brain is bigger than you
think perhaps you prefer petroglyphs
rock carvings with major cultural ties
that may refer to nearby places or
animals
watch out writing we're getting
uncomfortably close all of these
inventions helped humans keep track of
their thoughts so what makes writing
different
what's theme is afraid of let's talk
some Ness embeddedness these things are
all embedded in minds tasks rituals
events cultures rip them from those
contexts and you rip out their
expressive heart thoughts drug doesn't
come with so many strings attached it
will de-embed you letting you record any
specific thought and letting future
generations read it in any context so
human was Themis right is writing an
unnatural intrusion or do you want to
swallow thought spill and see for
yourself what we actually unleashed when
we invented writing
you